Donald Trump is now publicly denied
being a Russian agent that he has worked
for Russia during one of those yelling
over the helicopter question-and-answer
sessions outside the White House that
have become a sort of a commonplace way
for him to not really have to answer
questions because it's just so loud and
he's so rushed and the helicopter is
waiting for him and of course the fact
that we have a president denying this
sort of speaks to the absurd difference
between the situation today and the
situation with any recent president that
I can think of so let's think back in
reverse chronological order with Barack
Obama the questions were about policy
with george w bush the questions were
about policy no one was seriously
considering that the president might
have been at some point or still was as
a president an asset for a foreign
government we might say this decision
plays directly into the foreign policy
of a particular country or a group of
countries but with donald trump not only
is there a question of whether this is
an individual that is a de facto Russian
asset it's being discussed in media the
FBI was investigating the same and the
president has now publicly denied this
that is an indicator of how far the
Overton Window has sort of moved with
the types of questions we have to ask
about the President of the United States
I was even thinking back to Richard
Nixon even with Richard Nixon who
ultimately resigned in shame
amidst all of the horrible things that
he did there was not a question of is
Nixon a Chinese asset for example in
China particularly relevant when it
comes to Richard Nixon but here is
Donald Trump yesterday outside the White
House having to answer this question but
it's not even as simple as he makes it
sound here is in his answer take a look
at this I never worked for Russia and
you know that answer better than anybody
I never worked for Russia not only did I
never work for Russia I think it's a
disgrace that you even ask that question
because it's a whole big fat ho
so he's not he is denying it but he's
making it seem as though it's a very cut
and dried and simple thing as usual of
his own doing it is way more complicated
than he's pretending here remember that
compounding the insanity like a high
interest rate savings account to use an
analogy the insanity is that when that
wacky FoxNews judge Jeanine Pirro asked
him basically the same question he said
everything except for no it's not true
we played this clip on yesterday's show
this is just a reminder again it's not
as simple as Donald Trump is pretending
that it was yesterday in front of his
helicopter the FBI opened a
counterintelligence investigation the
day after you fired James Comey and in
May of 17 and the investigation was
whether you were actively working for
Russia or unwittingly so I'm gonna ask
you are you now or have you ever worked
for Russia mr. president I think it's
the most insulting thing I've ever been
asked I think it's the most insulting
article I've ever had written and if you
read the article you see that they found
absolutely nothing so as I pointed out
yesterday saying that they found nothing
is not a denial saying that it's an
insulting article is not a denial and in
the last 24 hours a bunch of hardcore
Trump is wrote to me and said David his
statement was fine it was a denial
nothing to see here
except we now have a report that Donald
Trump's own aides found that that denial
fell pretty short of what they would
have wanted White House aides are now
expressing regret that Trump didn't more
clearly and more forcefully deny being a
Russian asset on Jeanine Pirro show
absolutely stunning what we have taking
place right now not only was there an
FBI investigation into whether the
president is a Russian asset working for
a foreign country's interests above
American interests not only is the
president publicly being asked to
confirm or deny whether he's a Russian
asset his denials are barely denials and
they are raising even more
since including from his own staff at
the White House isn't it time now for
anyone who doesn't want to maybe be
working for a Russian asset to quit
working for Trump's administration
hasn't it gotten to that point or have
they decided they're going to go down
with the ship and maybe if they're
staying I mean I'm thinking out loud
here if you can survive this as a
staffer of Donald Trump's there's a case
to be made that you can sort of survive
anything
and maybe they end up with some great
job prospects by virtue of having been
able to survive this it's hard to
imagine anyone wanting to hire Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and Stephen Miller to
work for them at this point is going to
be particularly difficult to hire them
if they're in prison after this is all
said and done but that think that's
probably more wishful thinking at this
point the key message here is look at
how far the goal posts have moved from
there will never be an investigation to
one where there have been multiple
indictments we learned that an
investigation was opened by the FBI into
whether the president is an asset for a
foreign country in this case Russia and
his public denials of it are weak handed
at best the goal posts have moved and
that's what you need to remember today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom / Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 minute audio
book you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is calm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access
to thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n